i saw another guy
eat the white without touching the yolk
never touched the yolk until all he had
was the yolk in the center of the plate
and then he took his fork and he slid it
under the yolk
picked it up
we don't care about plot we care about
the human being in the story
yeah the human being is what matters if
the reader doesn't care about the human
being they could care less about the
plot everybody tries to come up with
plot
i mean plot's important
and
i could do a whole lecture on the
difference between plot and story there
is a difference story is the
chronological sequence of the events a
plot is how you arrange the sequences
and sometimes you don't always start at
the beginning go to the end sometimes
you start at the end and then you go to
the beginning and then you go to the
middle
you know then you have a flashback i
mean plot is is is much different than
story but
um
when you're writing a story or your plot
if the human
if the protagonist whether it's first
person or third person
if the reader doesn't care about that
character
why would they care about the plot
they they care about a character
and then they want to see what's going
to happen to the character and that's
the story
so
character is most important every writer
will tell you that it's almost a cliche
grab any writer any published writer off
the street and say what's the most
important thing in every character
now
once you've got your character
your character will lead you to your
story and to your plot
even if you've already got it made up
and figured out and outlined it
characters change their mind
characters don't always do what you want
them to do they will tell you what they
want to do and what they want to say and
all of a sudden your character
leaves for for tierra del fuego
and
i didn't plan on that but now they're on
a ship going to tierra del fuego and
they're meeting a
tall dark woman with a long cigarette
holder and a cigarette that has a long
ash whoa where do i go with that
you don't know it's accidental
so once you've got character
then
the character will create your plot and
where does character come from character
comes from the voice
if you're in the deep voice
and the character is narrating from the
deep voice or the third person narrator
is in the deep voice
that creates compelling character so
voice creates character character
creates plot
and it can be no other way right
can't reverse i would never say it can't
be any other way
what i'm saying is that in general um if
your story does not have a character
that people relate to
your story isn't going to be enough
and the way you get people to relate to
a character is through the authentic
voice
they hear that intimate voice and
suddenly that character
is real and is alive
but i'm not because it's the only way
it's the way i think it should be
because
that will succeed for you like i said i
don't think there's a writer out there
that will tell you character doesn't
matter
they're going to tell you character
matters
what are the steps to developing and
building a character
i actually teach a class in that
um
well one establishing the voice
how does that character talk
um how do they see the world
what is their attitude toward the world
and then you've got to collect a lot of
details
that i
have my students make a character
checklist
not for any one character but for any
character and you should be keeping this
checklist
um for the rest of your life
anytime you see something that looks
interesting about a character or you
think about it or you see it in a movie
or you read it in the book make a note
of it
and then when you start developing your
character
riffle through your your checklist and
see what you got that's kind of
interesting
um
so
you want to find things that make the
character compelling because of little
little things what do they keep in their
refrigerator how do they wear their
clothes how do they eat eggs
how do they eat sunny-side up eggs
so you should be paying attention you
know a lot of writers they don't pay
attention
they've been to a coffee shop or cafe a
hundred times and they've never really
looked at how people eat
if you look at how people eat
everybody eats a particular way the way
they hold a fork the way they cut their
food
um
sunny-side up eggs
you should watch
10 different people eat sunny-side up
eggs and every one of them will do it
differently
i saw one guy
he cut the white
put it on the fork
dipped it into the yolk okay
and eat it and
the yolk would come up
white you know so he would he kind of
kept doing that
i saw another guy
eat the white without touching the yolk
never touched the yolk until all he had
was the yolk in the center of the plate
and then he took his fork and he slid it
under the yoke
picked it up and i tell you i get this
to me there's
i couldn't do that
gets his fork under the yoke
and the whole thing like he'd been
waiting the whole meal to get to that
yoke now to me yolk creeps me out i've
got to mix it up um
when i was a kid
my dad would have to cut it all up for
me because i didn't even want to dip it
in the i wanted it all cut in little
pieces
and all mixed together it would be a
scrambled sunny-side up egg and i would
eat it that way
dipping my toast into it
if you look at people eat their food
you'll find a lot so you could do a
checklist on
hundreds of little things
about people what does their
refrigerator look like everybody's
refrigerator is looks differently and
when i go visit a friend or anybody's
house even if it's a stranger you know
someone says oh let's go over my
friend's house or something
i look at their refrigerator and i look
at their medicine cabinet oh and i look
at their books oh interesting i can tell
more about a person by their medicine
cabinet the refrigerator and the books
they have than anything else
whatever they are acting like i know
i'll know about them by that now
as a writer i'm going to make notes of
things i find interesting so that i'll
use that in a in a book for a character
you know people who have 10 day old milk
in the back or
or they have lots of uh tupperware and
everything is in there and it's going
it's already moldy
you know how do people arrange their
refrigerator some are are you know
obsessive-compulsive they've got
everything neat and perfect
so same with the medicine cabinet boy
cabinet tells you everything oh like
what you know someone's got a tube of
cream that's been blick and the cream
hasn't been used in about a year but
they've kept it because
who knows that rash may come back and
you can see the top the cream that was
squished out of the top is now brown
and it's
you know they didn't even press it
neatly or something one guy's got his
toothpaste and he rolls it as he goes
another person is squishing it here and
there and it's a mess so there's all
sorts of little eccentricities that you
can find in a medicine chest
make a note of them and keep it on your
checklist because one day you'll be
writing a story and you'll have a minor
character
and
you'll have an opportunity to mention
something in their medicine chest that
will be
interesting what about books what does
that tell you about well i always look
at books see what people are reading
you know i mean you never know what
people read
and and you always you'll find anomalies
too
you'll you'll find all their books about
one subject
and then they got one book on aristotle
and you go hmm what are they reading
aristotle for but then they'll have
another book on how to make a million
dollars in the stock market or or
something you know you just oh this
person's got one of their books that
they must have read in first grade and
they've
jimmy potts gets a haircut
and you open it and it's got little
illustrations in it and it's a story
about a kid
who gets a haircut and the barber
made a bad cut and some woman thinks he
was hit by a truck it's you know it's a
story for like a third grader and he
still got it i wonder why
gee i'll use that in the novel one day
so
you make notes of things that you think
are are interesting and you put it on
your checklist and you have hundreds of
things on your checklist all sorts of
things uh just their emotional truth and
just their anything and then when you
start writing a short story and you got
a character you think all right what
have i got on my checklist maybe i can
use some of this stuff
you know the way they clean their
glasses
the way they wear their glasses
um
the inside of their car
well that's another
thing like a medicine chest the inside
of the car i mean i knew one guy every
time i'd get in his car i'd say
why don't you grab a shovel and dust up
you know
it was that
you know it looked like
what he called the junkyard
or the ones with the serial killer clean
where you're like whoa
this thing's been get in the car that's
absolutely pristine yeah
wow a little freaky well i i don't know
i think i admire this person oh okay
they really worked hard
i'll have a penny on the mat
on the
you know not the driver's seat but over
there it's been down there for like
months and i just don't feel like
picking it up
and i kind of got used to being it down
there
i figure i'm not going to pick it up
let's see if someone else picks it up
and if someone else does pick it up i'll
go ah okay
character interesting
some people won't let sleeping dogs lie
and some people won't let lying penny
sit so you know you find out little
little things that that are interesting
um
i read a a detective novel a few years
ago a few years ago 30 40 years ago
and it was about
a character who's the main character in
all his detective novels who is a
detective and a crooked sheriff in a
small town in florida throws him in jail
for something
so
he's in jail for like two days and
he's just trying to
keep his sanity and figure out who did
the murder
but in order to keep himself occupied he
thinks of things
and one of the things he thinks about
and it's a two-page essay
uh you're not old enough to remember
this
but when i was a kid and you had skates
nowadays skates are attached to shoes
you just put your foot in the shoe
that's got the the roller skates
attached to it but when i was a boy
you had the metal skates that had little
clamps on it and it hooked your shoes
not tennis shoes you had to have shoes
that had you know rims on them that you
could hook it on
and then the way you would tighten it
would be with a little thing that looked
like a little wrench called the skate
key
and you always had to have the skate key
with you because you never knew when it
would
change and the skate would fall off and
you'd have to unscrew it put it back on
your shoe and then screw it again so
where did you keep that skate key well
90 of the kids who skated took the skate
key there was a little hole in it and
they put a string in it and then they
would tie the string around their head
and this skate key would hang here
he wrote two pages on a skate key
i don't remember anything about that
novel
except that essay on a skate key has
nothing to do with the story
totally irrelevant to the story
except it tells you something about his
character
and it became interesting
so
little things can be very fascinating in
books even a detective novel where i
remember that and i've forgotten
everything else
right
or latch key kids used to have the the
string
you know you could always tell in the
80s the latchkey kids yeah you know
and the latchkey kids would have a
string with the key right exactly and
you they we were told to hide them so
that people didn't know that you'd be
going home alone right
yeah
my observations yeah and an extra
quarter in your pocket in case you had
to call your mom right for a payphone
now every kid's got a an iphone sure
sure i remember driving around
somewhere where i was because i had to
call
my wife or maybe the person i was living
with i had to call him to tell him i was
going to be late and you're looking for
you know a little pay phone
sometime in a movie when that happens
i'll think to myself
why don't they just call them on their
iphone
and i go oh it's 1972. there is no
yeah i remember being on the phone
trying to call my grandmother letting
her know quote everything was okay it
was in a little bit of a rough part of
town and somebody was making a nefarious
deal and yelling about it the paper next
to me
and i'll never forget
he was really angry and i'm thinking
and my grandma was like is everything
okay oh yeah everything's fine
but that's la you know at that time with
the pay phones i don't know it could be
anywhere but you see what just happened
i talked about a skate about stuff in in
a medicine chest how you eat eggs a
skate key and then you thought about the
latch key and then we got into the
calling on the phone and you remembered
how you had to call your grandmother to
say everything's fine
and someone is yelling over there doing
some kind of drug deal or something it
was bad yeah there's a scene from a
novel
yeah and and which has nothing to do
with the story but it might be the the
event
that the reader never forgets
don't forget your plot sure but they'll
not they'll never forget that moment
where you're on the phone trying to tell
your grandmother you're fine and there's
a drug deal going on there and
somebody's yelling and screaming and
you're not exactly in the best part of
town right
because
a phone is a phone yeah oh yeah you
found the phone go make the call they
used to have three in a row you know
you'd go and then this person came after
i already got on the call and right i'll
bet you
a hundred dollars that if i give a young
person today
a quarter
and say there's a pay phone i want you
to make a call on the pay phone okay
they put the quarter in
and then dial the number
hi hi bill
yeah i'm i'm calling from a pay phone i
just i'm i'm
we have a bet going here okay all right
i just yeah i'm fine i'm fine okay hang
up
none of them
will check the little coin thing to see
if the quarter came back right
but when we did it when we were young
you did it because sometimes the quarter
would drop back into that little thing
and you'd get your quarterback right it
was such a treat but they wouldn't do
that because it wouldn't even occur to
them
sure
but those are little details too that
details everybody every writing teacher
will tell you details
you